all right we are now live
it's a Saturday late morning when I
would ordinarily be shooting some video
stuff and I am shooting video right now
right because this is a live feed
that'll go to the channel but it had
something big yesterday the airing of
the first episode of wisdom for life
radio show which I'm going to talk about
in just a little bit people have been
asking to see my hair down you know I
usually have got it pinned back so I
thought I would I would do that today
you can see it's quite long and you can
see why he keep it pulled back most of
the time because there's an awful lot of
it and it can get in the way quite
easily so let me actually knock out some
questions right at the start Lenny penny
has a meta question so you will not
answer our questions
yeah I'll answer questions it this is a
dr. Sandler philosophy pop up it's like
any other live thing usually I've got a
topic in mind that I'm going to talk
about and that's the wisdom for life
radio show and the experience of going
on air and all that but yeah I'll answer
questions and I should answer one right
at the start Nazim asks is there a way
for non-americans to listen to your
wisdom for life radio show of course
because like every other radio station
Riverwest radio has streaming online and
all you got to do is click on the show
page that's in the video description and
you'll be taken to it and you can even
hear it when it's not airing because the
archive there's stuff in SoundCloud so I
mean that's that's pretty much I think
the standard these days for most radio
stations you can you can stream them
pretty much anywhere apparently you can
also listen to it through a smart
speaker although if you say Riverwest
radio it will take you to some other
River West thing so you don't want to do
that you want to actually use the
station letter identifiers which are W X
R W I think for yeah WX RW River West
or you can you know you can listen I
think on satellite radio even although
I'm not not quite sure about that so
it's kind of a cool era now as far as
radio goes there's very few people who
actually listen to radio live when it
actually happens compared to the
worldwide replay audience for that and
and that's kind of that's kind of cool
so I'll answer some of these other
questions in a bit but first I'm going
to tell you a little bit about the show
so my co-host is Dan Hayes and he is a
guy who is you know he works in the tech
fields really into stoicism and he is
one of the co-organizers of the
Milwaukee stoical Fellowship so we got
to know each other quite well he he
spoke at stoic on X Milwaukee this last
year he was one of the invited speakers
and you know he and I have gotten
together a lot of times and and we
thought about the idea of doing a
podcast and there's so many podcasts out
there that we thought you know maybe
maybe not
and Riverwest radio is a community radio
station so that means you think about
like National Public Radio and all the
local affiliates and now go even further
down that line NPR is is still kind of
commercial compared to a community radio
community radio and there's not a lot of
stations out there like that
means that within reason anybody can do
a show you just yet but you have to
actually underwrite the show yourself or
find sponsors or stuff like that so
there's a lot there's a lot put on the
producers nobody's an employee except
for the station manager and and a few
you know a few other people and
everybody is essentially coming in and
volunteering to produce their show
you've got to make some commitments so
they don't get in trouble with the FCC
alright you can't say the seven words
that you can't say on the radio and
there's other things that are that are
involved as well that you have to get
training in but the shows can be
basically about anything although you
know they're sort of tapped out on
sports
music shows and I think maybe one other
time as well but nobody had ever pitched
a philosophy focused show so that's what
we thought yeah maybe maybe we'll do
that because the station manager had
been asking me for a while hey are you
interested in doing a show or not and so
so you know I said yeah okay maybe and
then with a co-host okay it's a little
bit easier to do the show when you're
not the only person on deck for it right
so Dan and I went in and we pitched the
show idea that we would be doing you
know something that had to do with
philosophy but in a popular sense how to
apply it you know we'd be going into
some rigor but we would be explaining
terms as we went along so that somebody
doesn't have a background what it would
easily be able to get some benefit out
of it and they said yeah sounds good and
then they said okay you've got to sign
up for the training and and you know
sort of it's almost like a certification
process so we had to learn about you
know all these different FCC issues and
regulations and what not to do and we
also had to like you know learn about
the ins and outs of the the sound board
and all of those kind of things as well
so yeah a lot a lot of fun and then we
had our last show our first show last
night and it went okay you know there
were a couple hiccups at the start Dan
who's actually better on the sound board
at this time I think he forgot to bring
a level up or something like that which
is really easy to do so this so one of
the other station people came in and
helped us out and you know we we had a
good conversation we had some things
planned out ahead of time we if you
listen to the show you'll hear that
we're talking about you know what the
show is about to begin with because it's
the first show and then we talk about
why philosophy is becoming more and more
popular
in you know across the world and I think
the Internet has a big big role in that
I mean think about what we're doing
right here right
none of you would be able to hear what I
have to say and I wouldn't be able to
see what you have to say if it weren't
for this this platform that we're on
right now so I think that's a huge thing
then we talked about the notion of
philosophy of life or philosophy as a
way of life sorry and you know a little
bit of Pierre at doe and you know
talking about ancient philosophy but
also you know existential ism even
Descartes is really philosophy as a way
of life if you read them properly then
you're not just sort of reading textbook
stuff and and yeah we we went through
that and then we talked about the notion
of philosophical practices and we took a
question that about setting boundaries
and you know whether one could do that
as a stoic or not or whether it means
letting people walk all over you the
answer's no it's not that's not quite
true and then what else oh we finished
up by by talking about a philosophical
practice which is negative visualization
which is you know it's not just the
Stoics who practice it but it's really
core to stoicism and then we wrapped up
and so good first show in the bag there
were some sound issues at the beginning
but otherwise it was okay and things
went pretty well
I actually got video recording of it so
I'm going to be putting that up once
I've got the video processed and the
other thing I'll say about the show and
then I'll start answering some some
questions is a friend of mine Scott -
rouille he did the music for it so if
you enjoy the intro music and the outro
music was very joe satriani ask you
might go over to scott truely's website
and check him out he is a guitar
professor at Berklee School of Music and
a gigging musician he's been you know
doing a lot of studio and gig work for
years and years he has his own band he's
got three albums really cool guy he and
I have been working together on
different projects for about four or
five years now
and we you know when we get the chance
because he lives
Boston we hang out as well so that's
that's kind of fun all right so let's
see what people have to to ask about
Lenny penny what is philosophy bring the
self development that psychology doesn't
well you got to define your terms right
so whose philosophy whose psychology
obviously a lot of psychology you you're
probably thinking psychotherapy rather
than just psychology because that would
include you know like experimental
psychology and all that other sort of
stuff you know it depends if you look at
the classical thinkers in psychology
many of them knew a lot of philosophy
some of them actually were philosophers
like William James for example right but
a lot of people who get training today
in psychology they don't really
understand the roots of their discipline
very well and they know the approaches
that they use but they don't understand
sort of bigger picture stuff or they've
got kind of a hazy concept of that not
saying that philosophers are necessarily
better as a matter of fact I would say
90% of philosophers in terms of academic
philosophers out there you wouldn't want
to bring into the conversation because
they only know their little thing as
well but if you do know if you've read
pretty widely in the history of
philosophy you see certain themes coming
up over and over and over again and if
you've got a real interest in say virtue
ethics and not in an abstract way where
well virtue ethics is one of the big
three you know different than a ontology
or or count you you know or a
utilitarianism right but you actually
like you know read the text and try to
apply them and see what people who who
are committed to that do which often
includes borrowing some stuff from other
moral theories then you're gonna have a
more comprehensive concept of the human
being which is also a reflexive concept
cuz you're not a robot you're a human
being
theorizing about human beings and then
you have a lot to offer to psychologists
but psychology also has a lot to offer
to philosophy when it's done well you
know so you know I've brought up this
this article over and over again that
would you can find in essays on
Aristotle's
ethics by Leslie Cosman on properly
being affected we're you know towards
the end of the the essay or a book
chapter rather Cosman is saying okay so
Aristotle's doing this this stuff that
we you know sort of interpreted out of
his works in terms of moral development
and what else what's missing in the
picture well psychotherapy could help
out spiritual direction and traditions
could help out and so you know you want
to think of these as sort of cumulative
processes but you you you really do have
to specify like which psychology are you
talking about you know CBT cognitive
behavior therapy and other cognitive
approaches may be bringing Aristotle the
Stoics some others into the conversation
can be very helpful for them because
they well they drew upon that that stuff
they also forgot a lot about it and
current therapists are not well well
trained in that usually you know
positive psychology I think that you
know virtue ethics can be a great
critique of that as can you know more
socially oriented philosophies that are
you know kind of later on you can think
of Marxism but you could also think of
what's come to be called conservative
liberalism Mill de Tocqueville right
they all have interesting things to say
about how the way in which society is
organized modifies the ways in which we
grapple with our ideas and habits and
stuff like that so and all of them would
be very critical of what we nowadays
call positive psychology as you can tell
I'm not a big fan of so you know there
there's a lot there and of course
there's been a long-standing interaction
between not just Freudian psychology but
but depth psychology in general and
philosophy so you know there's there's a
lot of ways to supplement them all right
Forrest has an assertion here to
question everything includes questioning
the validity of questioning everything
yeah and I think that a lot of people go
through that phase early on in in
philosophy when they discover that
and there's all sorts of interesting
linguistic tricks you can do like that
where there's some self referentiality
to it you know I don't know if it's
really the case that they all boil down
to the liars paradox I when I did my
senior thesis back in 94 I argued that
all truth self referential statement
groups could be either construed as
liars paradox which then could be
modeled as a mobius strip geometrically
or as mere tautologies but i don't know
if that's it's been long time since i've
looked at that stuff John asks how do I
think philosophy helps with the con vid
19 crisis I don't think it helps I mean
are you asking how it could help I don't
think anyone's consulting phosphorus
about it right now although we are
actually as part of the modern stoicism
team we're looking at actually putting
together some discussions about that I
mean you know the best thing you can do
if the the crisis is wash your hands
more often I don't think you need a
philosopher to tell you that right okay
I mean they could help you out figuring
out why you why you're disgust impulses
are getting away from you or you know
why it's a bad thing to be
you know withdrawing from any one
perceived as Chinese but again if you
need a philosopher to tell you that
you're probably in pretty bad shape but
you know they may be consulted on some
things we you know we can I suppose we
could say that epistemology who are
involved in social issues can certainly
help out when people are claiming that
the virus spread is a hoax and things
like that maybe maybe there's a role for
philosophy right all right so Ethan asks
how am i doing pretty good you know it
was cool to do the show I'm still kind
of excited about it a little chagrined
as well that the audio didn't work as
well at the start but you know those
things happen we're sort of getting our
as they
say see legs and I'm sure the next time
around we'll all have it better but I'm
glad that we had some great music to
fill in the gaps before the mics were
coming up so you know it's good thing
that we we had that track by Scott truly
Dale s I really enjoy learning
philosophy but it can cause a lot of
anxiety and any advice yeah so that I
think is kind of a common issue there's
there's quite a few there's quite a few
experiences in studying philosophy that
I think many people have and we probably
don't talk about enough and some of them
can be anxiety-producing so what are you
know think about what are the sources of
anxiety one of the biggest ones is am i
doing it right and the answer is well
yes and no I mean by whose criterion
right and and it's very common to have
like encountered philosophy and modes
that pretend like their philosophy with
a capital P and telling you how to do it
but they're really just a tiny little
sliver of the discipline so you know
it's it if you if you have a professor
who's like well doing philosophy is done
this way and that stuff over there isn't
philosophy then you might feel anxious
when you find yourself attracted to do
stuff you know in in other ways and
that's you know the cure for that is
realizing that the person who told you
that didn't know what they are talking
about and probably buys into their own
you know their own nonsense that that's
the only way to do philosophy again
reading through the history of
philosophy is a great remedy for that
because you see just how many ways
legitimate ways philosophy can be done
another I think another big thing is
like people read the texts I see this
with my students and I need to create
some videos about this for my students
because they they wind up getting quite
anxious about this you know reading
philosophy text is not like reading an
encyclopedia entry or
you know more popular literature you're
not gonna get it all the first time as a
matter of fact you know you're probably
not gonna get half of what's going on in
the text unless you've been doing
philosophy for quite a while and even
then you know like when I read something
I know that I'm gonna have to go back
over and over and over and over again
and so you know that's okay that's
normal
you don't really master philosophy I
know a lot of people look at philosophy
as if it's something like coding where
like you can get your certification and
this or that now you know all of this
stuff because you've read through
Spinoza 15 times you know and memorized
a bunch of terms it doesn't work like
that philosophy is a humanities
discipline and it's concerned with you
know the deepest topics and with wisdom
so you're never gonna master it you know
but you don't have to so you don't have
you don't have to place that burden on
yourself
and then you know I think I think a lot
of people get anxious about how well
they can articulate what they think and
that's you know again common experience
what else do people get really anxious
about am i reading the right people
that's that's a variation of am i doing
it right right
because you can't read everybody and
knowing who you should read is in large
respect it's not based on some sort of
rational decision procedure it's always
based on some sort of trust or faith in
somebody right so people ask me who
should I start with now start with Plato
right and then they'll say yeah but I
read the plate Plato's dialogues and I
didn't get anything out of it read him
again
you know well you know so-and-so said I
should begin with Russell's history of
philosophy well I mean if you trust him
or her more than you trust me then go
ahead and start with that and a lot of
its experiential - you read it see
whether you actually got something out
of it figure out whether you getting
something out of it or not getting
something out of it is a function of
where you currently are whether the text
is is you know any good and then then
you move on and you hopefully bring the
stuff with you so alright let's see here
[Music]
to do here we go
Alexandra asks what do I think about to
lose is difference in repetition you
know it's an interesting book I'm not a
huge fan of to lose but it's worth a
read I mean the books by him that I like
the best are probably the logic of sense
and then his essays critical in clinical
I think that's the English translation
of it and then you know I like quite a
few of his his other studies but you
know he you know he's he's worth reading
he's not it's kind of weird that there's
so much contemporary interest in him I
don't I don't get it I suspect a lot of
the people that are really into Deleuze
it's sort of like the people who are
into some well some of the other figures
because the lose is very difficult I
think a lot of the people who brag and
talk about to lose probably don't
understand to lose that well because you
know he is he's like deliberately
unsystematic right he's gonna subvert
and undermine and all this sort of stuff
and sketch out new possibilities but I
don't know that's that's just sort of a
aside social justice warriors of the
world quite a name there how can you
learn from your students and provide for
their learning new needs while also
attempting to maintain rigidity I
wouldn't say you try to maintain
rigidity you try to maintain structure
and substance and rigor right and so and
I'm not particularly concerned with
learning from my students that I think
that's kind of a become a buzz word
among educators oh I learned more
for my students than they learned for me
if that's the case then you know you
shouldn't be the instructor right I do
you know I do enjoy like seeing them
grapple with things and I do learn from
them in a way like oh here's a new way
that we could apply Plato and this this
notion of the tripartite soul because
they're offering me an example I haven't
seen before but I think it's better to
ask how do you maintain openness so that
students can explore and learn and and
find a guide that can help them with
things who's not like super hands-on
right not like saying oh you've got to
go this way but rather you know whoa
what would be the benefit of going this
way you know doing that sort of thing
and maintain all the other stuff and and
my answer is that well I like to provide
them a lot of resources and then say you
know see what works for you so you know
a lot of those core concept videos that
I have in my channel those are things I
use in my classes for my students and
that's why you know people are was like
why don't you do core concept videos and
so and so like I'm busy shooting stuff
for my students right now you know maybe
after I get all of that done I'll go to
whatever it is that you're looking for
or maybe I'll do something else you know
but you know the key is to try to meet
the students where they are you've got
to be able to speak their vernacular and
not in the sort of steve buscemi you
know holding a skateboard hat on
backwards saying how do you do kid
fellow kids the thing like that meme but
actually like stayin interested in the
the big picture things that they're
interested in and exposing them to that
and that just that hasn't been an issue
for me really never assuming that the
stuff that that I'm into as cultural
references is an automatic cultural
reference for them you know like you
always have to ask well what are what
shows are you watching you know and then
maybe you'll find some common ground
that you can use as examples
and and I think the other thing you know
too is we want to create lifelong
learners we don't want students who can
simply get through a course and then do
a brain dump of everything in their
final projects or exams or papers and
then never think about this stuff again
we want the materials that we've had
them engage with to leave you know
lasting traces on their soul so to speak
at and and we want to gear them into
like well where would they go for more
information so that's that's an
important part of my classes when I'm
doing it right you know some days I'm
probably not so all right let's look
down here
Bruno asks what are the benefits of
studying philosophical works what is
there to be gained in so doing wide
range of stuff I mean you you know if
you're thinking about practical
philosophy you're getting suggestions
that you can either follow or not follow
about how to make your life less screwed
up and how to understand your
relationships and the world and you know
the social matrix that we're in and
technology and yourself all of those
sorts of things right that that seems to
me to be a pretty good thing some people
are much more into like well no
philosophies primarily theoretical or
contemplative and that that's good too I
mean there's lots of things you can
think about in philosophy and there's
you know a wide range that you can you
can select from that's kind of nice as
well I'll tell you what having that
makes me think of something my
instructors were so jaded in an
undergraduate that they would say things
like well this idea will be useful for
you when you're standing around with
nothing to say at a cocktail party you
know and and I mean who's almost a
cocktail parties
we were like picturing ourselves at a
cocktail party and being like yeah I
don't I don't think I'm gonna
invited to those sort of events but you
know the idea that you would use it for
making like oh would you call it
culturally literate literate idle
chitchat to show that you belong in a
certain place I suppose that you'd gone
to college and learn certain concepts so
alien to the history of philosophy or
it's not alien to it that's exactly the
sort of thing that's a Descartes or Hume
or Hobbes
or you know others would have made fun
of and said those those those are people
who who are you know their philosophies
no good you know so alright ho despair
litter I guess is the name hello why do
you think people enjoy philosophy and
literature well that's my vast thing I
think that you can say that people love
stories and a lot of good philosophy
actually either has narratives or is in
the form of narratives think about
Aristotle's digressions you know he
loves to do that Plato's dialogues are
essentially narrative des cartes
meditations is a narrative you know we
could go on and on and on and so there's
that aspect of it and people like
thinking about ideas people the kind of
beings that we are we are we are truth
seeking beings doesn't mean that we
always find it but we enjoy being able
to make sense out of things
I mean Aristotle talks about this in the
rhetoric you know we like to learn
doesn't mean we all like to learn
academic subjects some people like to
memorize sports statistics and then
rattle them off when they're hanging out
at the bar with their buddies watching
the game and it's not just to make them
feel like a big shot or to be able to
have some sort of connection it's it's
it's also because they enjoy learning
and understanding those things so I
think that's a part of it as well all
right mirac has a question about the
phenomenology of spirit that I don't
think I'll be able to answer on the fly
I want to ask about the phenomenology in
paragraph 227 how does Hegel pass to
priestly mediating consciousness from
paragraph 226 where it comes from
I don't know I have to go back to the
text and look it's not like I memorized
Hegel and have him on tap and my brain
you know probably look in the paragraphs
before that or think about the fact that
mediation plays a constant role in all
of the dialectics and then you know
think about what Hegel's trying to
trying to get out there I'm not quite
sure what you're looking for that
yep a what's your thoughts on Immanuel
Kant's philosophy on radical evil
well can't says that you know we can
always go wrong
I think he's actually right I think that
you know acquiring the virtues makes us
less likely to do that but can't isn't
the first person to come up with this I
mean John Cassian talks about cases of
monks who live to this this saintly life
their whole life and then like in the
last year they just like go downhill and
screw things up and you know it could be
that they weren't living that saintly of
life you know we can't look inside their
heads and actually see what their soul
was maybe they're just trying to you
know like be the saintly type or
something like that but counts basic
point is that you know it there's always
the possibility of doing wrong and for
Kant doing wrong isn't just like
transgressing against the moral law it
would also include a sort of you know
attitude that subordinates the moral law
to something else like say getting rich
or you know satisfying your desires so I
guess you could say my view on it is
he's right but but it's not a strictly
conscient thing he just has that term
Lennie says I look like a medieval king
with my hair down okay I mean I don't
have all the other accoutrements of a
king like a crown or what is that thing
that they like an orb with the stuff
that they'd have or a scepter any of
that sort of stuff
Andre asks any thoughts on pureed oh
yeah I think I doze on to stuff again I
don't think what he's doing is really
original he's sort of realizing things
that other people in the 20th century
we're writing about quite a bit they
just didn't call it by the same name and
dough became popular and and they were
forgotten or less so I mean Maurice
blown Dale his first book oxy all 1893
says that that you know philosophy is
essentially about putting things into
practice right
Gabrielle Marcel said that you know we
can go on and on and on and on and I
know himself says you know ancient
philosophy was was understanding
philosophy is something that's lived
having you know a set of practices that
are connected with with Experion
Experion shil things with texts often
with communities but he also sees that
happening and a lot of other points in
in philosophy and he talks about you
know existentialist
as being like that so you know it's it's
good to read a doe I think a lot of
people you know this is very common in
the history of ideas a lot of people
like latch onto something they're like
oh my god this is the the new thing and
look at how brilliant this is and
nobody's ever said this before and then
when you read around a bit you're like
yeah he's saying the same thing as all
these other people were saying so that's
cool that he's bringing it back into the
forefront but let's not go crazy over
this and pretend that like philosophy
never knew this until this guy shows up
on the scene
yeah so alright let's let's go on as
we'll ask when can we expect the
philosophy fire made in book in the
Barnes & Noble philosophy section I
don't know maybe somebody's working on
that I I don't you know I'm not gonna be
the one who does that I got enough other
projects I actually had an interesting
conversation about a week and a half ago
with the the head of the Marquette
Institute for the advancements of the
humanities James South who actually does
quite a few of those popular culture
books and I asked him has anyone done a
venture brothers and philosophy book and
because I haven't seen one coming out
and I really like the Venture Brothers
and he said no and there's a matter of
fact I pitched it and they turned it
down so I don't think there will be a
book and I was like oh that sucks
because you know that's the sort of
thing I'd probably want to contribute a
chapter to you know is there any chance
that they'll reconsider maybe after
another season comes out he says I I
don't know you know we'll have to see I
mean you could put out like different
bands and philosophy
I suppose I heard made and it would be
kind of fruitful for that but I gotta
say a lot of the a lot of the popular
culture studies people to me I don't I
don't I don't really enjoy their stuff I
find it kind of faddish so I could just
imagine what all the the hipsters who
want to write about iron made and would
submit so yeah all right Sean him well
how do you deal with philosophers who
say the history of philosophy is
pointless I'm doing a PhD in philosophy
one or the historical influence and I'm
getting annoyed at hearing this well you
can just say to yourself well that that
that person's a dummy they don't know
what they're talking about you don't
have to say it out loud but you could
just like say it in the back of their
head because I mean it's just a stupid
thing to say
and I think a lot of people say it out
of cliquish ness or insecurity they
don't they don't understand a lot of you
know past philosophers and so they just
kind of dismiss it but they don't know
what they're missing I don't think you
actually need to try to like provide a
response to them I mean the irony is
most of the time the work that they're
doing is so unimportant that they're not
going to make it in the history of
philosophy they're gonna be forgotten
soon after they shuffle off whatever you
know appointment they have and they're
not going to make it into the longer
history you know a lot of a lot of the
better philosopher
are very cognizant of at least some of
the history of philosophy so nuba fights
pardon what are some of the key
differences between the philosophies of
Descartes and Aquinas well I'll give you
one Aquinas is hila morphic you know
body and soul go together and you know
manner in form and Descartes thinks that
they're two different kinds of
substances mind and an extended
substance so there's there's one right
there all right let's see fantasy world
history simulator
I've been reading dairy down I'm
wondering what you think of his concept
under of SU rats who were writing under
erasure you know I think it's that one I
think is probably one that's probably
not going to stick around you know
Derrida is one of these people who wrote
a lot and introduced a lot of ideas many
of which are what Plato and the
theaetetus would call wind eggs right
when he has Socrates talking about how
he's a idea Midwife right he helps
people bring their ideas to fruition and
then we see whether they're living and
can continue on their own or whether
they're what he calls you know gets
translated as wind egg but we could also
say miscarriage right I think that
probably you know I'm sort of picking a
number out of the air probably 85% of
dairy dies various ideas are
miscarriages they're not going to go
anywhere and I could do anything with
them you know talking about for example
there's nothing outside of the text I
think people will still be talking about
that you know in in the next millennium
if people are still around and it'll be
like you know it'll be like you know the
equivalent of cobblestones history of
philosophy the chapter on dorita Derrida
introduced these these ideas and some
people will still be getting some some
use out of it just like we get a use out
of like you know Heidegger is being
towards death right that that I
or that concept but I think that a lot
of dairy dows ideas are and the same you
can say for most of his generation
you know Foucault probably more fuko's
ideas are gonna survive to lose leotard
you know all of that that group Dan the
man have I been successful in getting
friends or family into philosophy or
philosophical pondering no not usually
not not not as as like doing philosophy
but I do find myself surrounded by a lot
of thoughtful people and so there's a
lot of room for at certain points saying
well you know so-and-so talked about
that and it could be helpful for you to
check that out or read it I'll mention
that with my kids like neither one of
them are gonna specialize in philosophy
and I'm cool with that
you know I don't think that children
have to like you know carry on the
legacy of their parents you know my
oldest is looking at musical theater
right now and and probably going to
school for that and my youngest is right
now wanting to be a quantum physicist
but I'm sure that'll change later on
down the line and I you know I I'm cool
with them doing something else because
you can always go back to philosophy and
yeah I have conversations with them
where we'll talk about philosophical
topics but we don't you know we don't
sit down and read Plato or something
like that all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
skip people have already asked quite a
few questions and jump on other ones
parabot Co and why do you think
Machiavelli deserves as bad reputation
or do I think Machiavelli deserves as
bad reputation I don't think he deserves
a reputation as bad as he's kidding
right and that reputation was there
already
like in the 18th century Frederick the
Great wrote a book specifically called
ante Machiavelli right so clearly there
were a lot of people who did not like
the implications of the prince I mean
there's actually some good stuff in the
prince you know he's got some
interesting discussions of class
dynamics why the rich are usually gonna
be pricks and try to like control
everything and why how you how the ruler
has to like you know rein them in and
how the poor are not you know innocent
lovelies themselves and you know what
you need to do but it's it's um you know
you can think of it as a book for crises
it's not really a book for how you ought
to run your life unless you want to you
know be miserable and alienate all the
people from yourself which I think maybe
some people on some level do so there's
a lot of business people who like they
claim that they're reading Machiavelli
and getting a lot out of it again I
think a lot of people talk about the
books that they're reading or the
authors at they're reading and only like
pick up certain little little parts of
it all right wiggly shirt how do I make
the most out of a great work Wow that
depends on what great work it is I
suppose you know you know you should you
should I mean I guess you can say
there's some some negative things like
don't speed read it you know don't try
to read it to claim that you've you've
you know accomplished it or something
like that if it's a great work people
have been going to it over and over and
over again because there's there's a lot
of rich stuff there and so I think
you're gonna wanna I don't see you don't
approach it like with some sort of
referentiality
oh my god it's the wonderful you know
text of Aristotle he must not be wrong
at anything but you know you should you
should approach it and say well I'm sure
there's something here because other
people seem to be getting a lot out of
it and you know the closer you're
getting time maybe a lot of things that
we
great works right now are gonna turn out
not to be quite so great 20 years from
now that that's probably helpful all
right
M X 25 a if I'm a die-hard air follower
can I say that human evolution is just a
hypothesis open a debate because there's
no way to verify it so human evolution
is just a fun fiction I mean I guess you
could but that'd be kind of a silly
thing to do and you know that's one of
the things we probably want to look at
your motivations for that right and you
also want to read the text see what air
actually has to say about verification
not all verification is exactly the same
think about how you you know what sort
of circumstances would lead you to say
that something is verifiable in
principle I don't think air would say
that evolution isn't Joseph's March what
sort of moral frameworks do you follow
I'm a virtue ethicists you know and I'm
eclectic in that so all right let's see
what just jumped let's see what we've
got here scroll back up I mean let me
point out to you that I'm probably not
going to get to everybody's questions
because people keep adding more and more
all right
Cola
I was thinking lately about micro
philosophies and whether or not they can
exist for example kind of philosophy of
flossing teeth exists it's sort of like
the you know Aristotle talking and the
rhetoric about the person who came up
with the Pangaea Rick about salt you
know I guess I mean you could write a
book about it it doesn't mean that
there's like a whole actual discipline
about you know flossing your teeth I
don't I wouldn't I wouldn't call it
philosophy of I would say philosophical
approaches to X you know like should you
floss your teeth
you could look at that from egos
perspective I don't know do you want
your teeth to fall out
or you want to you know keep them for a
while well it's in your interest to keep
maybe you should floss them or do what I
do use a Waterpik right um you could
look at it from utilitarian perspective
you could look at it in a day anta
logical perspective you know God gave
you those good teeth or you know the
universe gave you these teeth it's not
rational for you to not floss and take
care of them but ten whole philosophy of
it probably not you know although google
it see if there's somebody out there
who's got something on it here's a great
question from Arturo how should one deal
with [ __ ] professors or professors
that don't teach well yeah you don't you
don't actually have much power as a
student in relation to the professor and
you know it's good to make a distinction
between people who just don't teach well
because they're not they're not very
experienced in it or they're kind of
clueless or they're not very invested in
teaching and then people who are
actually genuine [ __ ] and say it
take take you know pleasure in
humiliating students or assigning
assigning work that they know the
students are gonna do poorly with or you
know we'd have a lot of professors who
do you know have these sort of asides
about you know they'd be very defensive
about how important the stuff that
they're studying was and how we wouldn't
appreciate anything from it and you
could have a teacher who plays favorites
too that's that's a problem I think that
ventures over into the [ __ ]
rain is not rain not régime either
region there you as well how to deal
with them
well remind yourself that your main goal
is to get through the class that's
that's a big one and that you don't have
to necessarily speak up for philosophy
you're not gonna get any mileage out of
like you know confronting them most
likely but it couldn't hurt to you know
send an email to the chair and say
listen paying for this class I'm not
getting out of it what I want or what I
what I was hoping for because and not
because the material is bad as a matter
of fact I really enjoy this material but
this professor is not doing what he or
she should you know I mean we actually
had a professor who eventually got fired
when I was in grad school who was a
terrible drunk and only got fired
because he he went after undergraduate
students groping them and then he got
first again you know we'll send you over
to our branch school in Japan to sober
up and learn not to do that which didn't
happen at all and then he came back and
kept doing it and then you know one of
the undergraduates was like hey this guy
was disciplined before and they they
didn't do anything about let's do the
school then they got rid of him right
away but you know you you don't have to
do anything like that just just you know
just send an email and you know I would
say in that case you're probably not
going to get out of the class what you
want and that's on that's on unfair and
it's it's unfortunate but you know the
key thing is for you to get get that
information elsewhere right all right
I'm gonna skip over the Deleuze question
because we talked about to lose before
[Music]
vishal asked why do people level
philosophers as lunatic creatures I
don't know that that's the case so it's
kind of a non-starter cambric I'm gonna
be teeing for the first time for liberal
arts math class next term should I try
to make things clearer as they make
sense to me or should I just follow the
textbook and professor maybe both maybe
maybe that's something where you try to
and you could you could actually present
it as well I'm gonna give you this first
and then I'm going to give you this
first and let's see if there's any
contrast between those that could be
really useful
your students and you know different
students are going to benefit from from
different approaches so I think that
could be good
factotum I've noticed you've been
delving into our theory lately any
intention of making a video on Joseph's
voice in his social plastic sculpture no
the only reason I've been talking about
art theory is because I have a class
ethic for artists and designers and I
was looking at a few things where
there's some overlap there you know the
Tolstoy and Dickey and who else today I
think that maybe all that I actually hit
on for the time being
eventually I'll probably put together a
philosophical aesthetics class for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and shoot a lot of other core concept
videos in aesthetics but that's that's
down the line for the fall I'm actually
teaching world religions and a 15-week
existentialist course for them so
alright let's see a a you often say we
shouldn't buy a single Philosopher's
narrative on the history of philosophy
what do you think is the biggest flaw
and the narrative presented in after
virtue well and this this is this is
kind of a common thing I think that
MacIntyre I think he writes off
Hellenistic philosophy a little bit too
easily
you know casting the Stoics essentially
as precursors to Kant there is something
of that in there especially when you
look at like Cicero's on ends book three
but it's it's not a sufficient treatment
and a long wrote a great piece you know
from a MacIntyre in perspective saying
you know really you're saying
Aristotle's the the remedy to Nietzsche
the Stoics would also provide an equal
parallel track for that sort of thing
and you know and McIntyre is very clear
he says listen I haven't covered
everything nobody actually can you know
we're past the time of Hegel where
people thought you could and there's
gonna be some gaps so yeah all right um
let's see here Eirik lists in I'd like
to ask what's your favorite method of
taking notes and how important if all do
you think it is taking notes is not that
important for me I take notes generally
when I've got thoughts that I want to
work out and plan to get to later and
very often I don't get to them or when
I'm like in a like back and forth sort
of thing and I need to actually take
notes on what somebody's saying or I'm
having a session with somebody and I
need to take notes which is a different
kind of note taking or when I'm doing
research that is going to culminate in a
presentation or academic paper and my
ways of taking notes I think are pretty
idiosyncratic and wouldn't be helpful
for anybody else different people will
have have very different approaches to
that so I don't have any I don't have
any like techniques or stuff like that
with all sorts of things same thing with
Manama cos I don't I don't really use
them I just rely on my memory so I'm not
I don't have anything very helpful to
say there um all right to do Chris
shuttleworth I know you stated your role
as a historian and interpreter
philosophy more than an original thinker
which is cool but what are you most
proud discoveries in philosophy
well let me say right off the bat that
originality is overrated and that much
of the people who are not doing history
of philosophy are not doing original
work
they're just regurgitating the same
stuff over and over and over again so
it's not like you know being a historian
of philosophy versus being an original
thinker as a matter of fact most of the
original thinkers
are pretty good in the history of
philosophy great example that would be
Heidegger or Alistair MacIntyre hey so
you know it's a false dichotomy and and
it's a dichotomy that's made by people
who generally want to write off history
they're all there are also some amazing
historians of philosophy who come up
with some very original ideas on regu ei
is a great example in in French history
of philosophy sort of mid 20th century
thinker not everything he's written has
been translated unfortunately but you
know so this is not this is not the sort
of contrast that that people make I mean
in my work on an Anselm I think I've in
some of the articles that I've got
anything I've managed to identify some
interesting themes and come up with some
useful turns of phrase to try to explain
his rather complicated moral theory and
views on freedom and causality you know
I've done things like that every once in
a while with Aristotle being able to
identify Hobbes as having a totalitarian
conception of reason not just a
conception of reason that that can lead
to totalitarianism but but something
like that you know there's there's
things like that along the way but
[Music]
here's what here's something that I
think it's left out good interpretation
is a creative act you're engaging with
the subject and trying to give it new
voice new life that's that's part of why
I like doing translation work
I love taking somebody else's words and
saying if I can put them into something
else and again I think that our our
conceptions of originality are quite
often overblown so
Montana what exactly does Descartes mean
by extension bodily substance things you
could measure you know just look and see
what he says in the discourse and the
meditations he's got he's got some
treatment so that or you know you can go
if you wanted to the principles of
philosophy that that's by the way the
principles of philosophy that's what
Descartes was hoping was going to be the
book that that would you know people
would go to write is gonna replace the
manuals in in stock in the philosophical
world of his time didn't really pan out
like that so much
Joseph March did I enjoy the good place
I watched the first few episodes with my
wife
neither of us enjoyed the first few
episodes we felt they're quite heavy
handed and the sort of stuff that you'd
roll your eyes at I'm told that it got
better as things went on but the things
that people have told me about it makes
us sound like it got not great better
but marginally better I don't know if I
have the time down the line maybe I'll
watch it but I think there's enough
people already doing work on that that I
don't need to bother with it
right now I'm you know we've been
watching better call Saul that's a great
series you know and nobody's like
putting philosophy on the chalkboard but
they're doing a hell of a lot better job
with ethics then I saw anything
happening in the good life so you know
also looking forward to Westworld
coming out quite soon so yeah all right
um
[Music]
made of clay I don't know what it means
to love oneself when one can't mean it
without lying been told before I'm loved
by people who didn't mean it and I don't
want to do that to myself how could it
be authentic well I suppose you could
begin by you know putting aside what
other people have said in the past and
realize that there's no intrinsic
connection between what they've said and
what you can see to yourself so that
might be helpful
and you know it's not so easily set not
so easily done it said there are stuff
is always going to come popping up and
you know it may even be like linguistic
formulations that you hear in your head
what we call self-talk and you have the
choice to talk back to yourself and say
well that's [ __ ] or I'm putting that
behind now not loving oneself because
you can't mean it without lying that
sounds sort of like you you're
struggling with you know I don't want to
say oh you're a great person when I
think I'm not a great person okay then
you're not a great person that doesn't
mean that you're unlovable that means
that there are some things that are good
and some things that are bad and then
you can identify and distinguish those
things and congratulate yourself on the
things that you've managed to do well
and you know see if you can find things
about yourself that you you do like and
the things that you don't like you have
the capacity to change them over time
right so if you want to be lovable and
you find yourself thinking that you're
unlovable because you lose your temper
too often with people start researching
anger management you know there's
there's plenty of resources out there or
you know there's all sorts of things
that you can do along those lines but
you don't have to let other people's
viewpoint on that
drag you down and authenticity is not
something that you attain like flipping
on a light switch it's a gradual process
so you don't have to be authentic right
now you know a polygraph what is
national identity is it an artificial
social contract construct or something
else yeah it's it's an artificial social
construct it's based on commonalities
that people share like coming from a
certain area or having genetics in
common or language in common but it's
usually most it's usually like 90%
[ __ ] right I mean think about
American national identity and all the
silly stuff that we associate with it
half of which isn't even true you know
and then a lot of which is kind of
twisted around and the real story has
been left out
yeah and yeah I mean that's not to say
that we shouldn't care at all about our
nation but we shouldn't be invested in
ideological conceptions of the nation
all right let's see here
moon child asks do I have students who
take my class and continue to pursue
philosophy if so do they catch up with
you in your office hours to discuss
other philosophers sometimes sometimes
they email me sometimes they get in
touch with me in other ways I tell
students as my classes end that when
they find themselves using concepts from
the class I want them either to email me
and to email me at my business address
because I might not be teaching at that
place at that time or to do it through
LinkedIn and I get quite a few who do I
also have quite a few students when I'm
teaching like a survey class you say
what are you teaching next semester and
you know you know at marquette often
times I'll say I don't know you know
they may or may not have me teaching for
them if I am - probably business ethics
you know that's the only upper level
class I teach for them if it's Milwaukee
Institute of Art in design I have
students who now have taken two three
classes with me and I see them in the
halls and and you know they don't really
come to the adjunct office but we we
chat about stuff when I run into them so
and I often see a lot of my students
around town as well which is kind of
nice
Carthage I've only been teaching
therefore this is my second semester so
I don't really know that much about
what's going to happen with that so all
right let's see here Sean Hamill there's
a good question if Trump refuses to give
it power if he loses the election would
that be the beginning of the end for the
American Republic would it be a Salah or
Caesar moments yeah I think you could
say that
and there is a danger of that you know
and the the danger doesn't just lie in
Trump and his administration and the
revolving door of you know lackeys who
who go through it it's in his base of
pretty nutty people who I've seen you
know go from being halfway reasonable to
being like you know cult followers who
are and some of them have his family
members you know and you're like man
this is a bad sign if you know if you
know the history of totalitarian
movements and you know not just that but
also you know who's and how how
Republic's and democracies and and
anything let's just say representative
government breaks down we're in a pretty
bad place so yeah they're I think
there's going to be some some serious
issues here Carlos and Joseph say thanks
for for my work well thank you that's
that's very nice let's see what else we
can hit on quickly
mg d'amour do I think yogurts criticisms
as Hegel were going in the right
direction or was Kierkegaard unfair to
him in any way I think that a lot of the
time Kierkegaard is not criticizing
Hegel as such but criticizing the hey
galleons of his time he thought that
Hegel was sort of like Socrates kind of
representing the best that philosophy
that does not orient itself by faith but
takes faith as an object to use a
starting point a sort of content that
has to be then philosophically developed
I think he thinks that's the best that
Hegel can do so you know Nick regard can
be pretty scathing that's right but I
don't think he's being radically unfair
to to Hegel but you should remember the
the you know Hegel's ideas by that time
had really filtered through the
philosophical establishment
and a lot of you know a lot of galleon
ISM was not quite as advanced as what
Hegel was doing all right
shady what's your opinion about Albert
Camus whose philosophy I like Camus
quite a bit
Watergate what Greeks do you think are
important for understanding German
idealism I don't know that's that's a
good question why why what Greeks I mean
obviously Plato and Aristotle because
there's references to them you probably
don't need to know that much about
Hellenistic philosophy because the
people in German idealism don't usually
get the Hellenistic philosophers write
or draw that much I mean you know you
could look at some of the pre-socratics
stuff because there's references being
made there but I don't think I don't
think it's really that important all
right eebee what do you think of the the
work of paul ricoeur I do like Recor
quite a bit I think he was he's an
underrated philosopher I I like a lot of
the work that he's done Dmitri do I
think numbers are discovered or invented
some of them are discovered I'd say in
some are perhaps invented you know you
think about well it's not to say I mean
so think about I all right the square
root of negative one you'd be tempted to
say well that's that's definitely
invented but it does get used in
understanding electrical current so it's
corresponding to something out there
right so I guess that could be
discovered as well Matthew have you read
Martin Darcy's mind and heart of love I
have not shen ming-liang can i elaborate
a bit about a nietzsche on the self yeah
there is a self but it's way more
complicated than we think and it's not a
unity and what unity it has is some
parts of the self imposing them on other
parts of the self and so you know it's
not as if there isn't anything
there that we can call the self but it's
it's it's a mess you know all right let
me take maybe one or two more things
we're already a little bit over time and
I got to get to to work pretty soon
of course I'm working here okay I got a
lot of things I have to do Jordan
aha me what do I see is the major
differences between so-called Western
philosophy versus Eastern philosophy I
don't I don't recognize that that
distinction you know it's not like
there's a box of Western philosophy and
Eastern philosophy and there's so much
stuff going on in just let's say we take
it's just a Chinese tradition all right
and we we expand that to include Korea
and Japan which may be a mistake by
itself but and China also was getting
ideas coming to it from from the West as
well because of the you know the the
Mongol Empire and all these other sort
of things there's there's parallels
between different things and I always
avoid generalizing about Eastern
philosophy or even non Western
philosophy in general you think about
how vast the Western philosophical
traditions are and then you start
reading some reading around in Chinese
literature and you realize that that's
just as vast and so is the same thing
with the Indian subcontinent so it's
it's not I don't think it's very
productive to like well you know the
West is rational and the East is
intuitive I think that's complete
[ __ ] you know there's plenty of
people who make appeals to intuition in
the West and you know there's plenty of
people in India and Chinese philosophy
are very rationalistic so many those
sort of things don't usually hold up
um let's see if we can find another nice
easy one to go out on so here's here's
one Montana home odd or is it really
feasible to try to learn ancient Greek
being a person that knows only knows
English yeah it's gonna take a lot of
work you're probably an advantage if you
do not just know in the sense of being
able to like hear and speak and read
like having gone through like duolingo
or any of these sort of apps you know
rosetta stone but I actually understand
the structure of another language you
know having like done things the
old-fashioned way with like memorizing
paradigms and learning you know rules
and perhaps you've been doing some as I
did comparative into your indo-european
linguistics that really helps you when
you go to study a language like Greek
which has cases that you need to learn
in tenses and all these endings and and
you don't know where the endings are
coming from or why that's important
right if you already know some Latin and
German or some other things that you can
compare to it makes it easier but it's
not an insurmountable thing I mean
there's there's books out there and
courses out there that you can do so you
know I think that can be quite helpful
all right well let me go out on this one
then Kyle Holly would I be interested in
exploring more art theory in the future
Benjamin's famous essay perhaps talking
about the work of art in the age of the
mechanical reproduction or TS Eliot's
metaphysical poet's essay yeah sure but
like everything else it's dependent on
the time that I have and what I'm
currently teaching like I said I'm down
the line I'll be teaching a
philosophical aesthetics class for
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and pointing that way because that it's
over that way it's about a mile from
here but you know until then I probably
won't be shooting videos on that stuff
because I've got other stuff to do
instead or I don't know maybe maybe I
will
I'm not a big fan of benjamine I think
that that si is kind of overrated but
you know people get a lot of mileage out
of it and I've shot a lot of videos on
other philosophers who I think are
overrated as well so why not hate
alright so I'm going to go out by
actually saying it a little bit
we started talking at the very beginning
about the wisdom for life show which I
co-host with with Dan Hayes here in
Milwaukee for Riverwest radio you can
see the link to it if you want to hear
the first episode it's it's up it's
available and we're gonna be doing that
every second Friday well every other
Friday rather a little bit too much of a
commitment to try to do it every single
week and we're gonna be talking about
how you know philosophy can be applied
to to life and we'll be drawing on a
number of different traditions of
philosophy and hopefully people will get
something out of it I don't see anything
else like this on the radio in the
Midwest so it's kind of a unique thing
and you can listen to it
Friday's 5:00 to 6:00 p.m. Central time
on the river west radio site if you're
actually here in Milwaukee you can turn
it you know it so 104.1 FM and listen to
it there so and you know I'll put in a
pitch to for River West radio it's a
community radio station if you're
looking to throw a little money at
something you can always donate to it
they have a lot of cool shows they make
it possible for a lot of voices in the
Milwaukee community to be heard that
otherwise wouldn't get on the air so if
you're looking for somebody to donate to
maybe check them out alright so I'm
going to sign off now thanks for all of
your questions and I hope you have a
great day or evening or night or you
know whatever it happens to be where you
are